Geron is a bad character that's what I
said back in November of 2017 I went on
the record and voiced my indifference
and frustration regarding Durin's
character however at the time many
considered it too early to draw an
accurate conclusion and that's fair
enough
I still hated him but that was a fair
enough conclusion to draw fast forward
24 episodes later and not only has the
opinion tonnes earned within the
community shifted but the generally
negative feelings surrounding him have
reached fever pitch and despite a large
portion of the fanbase hating gern as a
character I find myself unsatisfied yet
again disagreeing with the majority but
how could that be the case if I attack
Jared so earnestly before and he's still
the same what's changed today I am going
to break down
Jared's character touching on his design
personality and his backstory hoping to
reach a conclusion once and for all on
whether or not sure in the gray is in
fact a bad character and I think the
answer may surprise you
Jaron was introduced to the hive line
that is the Dragon Ball fandom on
episode 85 of Dragon Ball super now we
did sorta kind of see him in proto
material before the arc but I'll touch
on that later after episode 85 Jaron
didn't participate narrative Li in any
meaningful way until episode 96 in which
Goku singles him out as the guy to fight
in the contest I think this is the
moment where in the minds of many fans
the seeds of I hate Geron were planted
the tournament just begins and we are
told right off the bat that this guy is
the best so on the most basic level this
seems exceedingly cheap however it being
the beginning of the tournament most of
us including myself we're willing to
wait to see how things would pan
but already fans were taking issue with
a certain aspect of him
trying to break down the nebulous notion
of what makes for a bad character design
is very difficult was it largely boiling
down to her own basic preferences and
interests that said it is an intriguing
topic of discussion as characters with a
lot of thought put into them can't
convey a host of information to the
viewer at a glance for instance if you
look at these individual parts you
already know what they are that's an
engine those are wheels etc etc combine
these parrots with a host of others and
it becomes what everyone recognizes as a
car but if you take the wheels off of
this car people maybe even you would
still refer to this as a car what if you
remove the engine the brakes when does
this car stop being a car because an
engine isn't a car it's an engine so
there must be a point this car stops
being a car this is what I mean by bad
character design being a nebulous
subject when does a bad design become a
good design or vice versa a youtuber by
the name of super eyepatch wolf put this
better than I ever could the kind of
design that we are going to relate to is
as varied as what type of person we are
going to be attracted to design is what
the character looks like and how we take
that information in will inevitably
differ from person to person so this is
my take on Durin's design he's boring
okay let me explain his design is very
simplistic and by the books sporting a
top-heavy muscular frame which isn't bad
in my opinion just nothing to write home
about one aspect that did bother me was
the attire that he wore ignoring the
argument that the pride trooper uniform
is better suited to a comedic role which
it has been used in the same uniform is
worn by nine other characters who
between them haven't eliminated a single
person further diluting its appeal and
removing any sense of occasion and
respect that it has for comparison's
sake let's take a look at my favorite
character design from the entire series
Frieza his cold and sterile design helps
to convey his personality perfectly if
someone was to walk in and look at
Frieza on TV with no information they
would have a decent handle on his
character and what he's about so in
saying that does jaren's design have the
same
at first glance mmm kinda Joran is quiet
and stern and I'm not sure if that is
immediately understood just by looking
at them it could be the case that it
does in fact do that for you however for
me it's serviceable at best one thing I
will say is that I am thankful that
Joran has a strong build for a character
Dragon Ball super has enough skinny
strong characters so it was refreshing
to see someone of Geron stature finally
show up button saying that his design is
nothing special it's serviceable the
next part though might be harder to pull
off Frieza not only works because of his
design but also because of his
personality filled to the brim with
self-importance five seconds with Frieza
and you'll be dying to see him on your
screen again in the same vein cell is
smarmy and smug and Boo is volatile and
savage while I am hoping to get across
here is that a character's personality
is arguably its most important aspect I
mean Vegeta is a short angry looking
troll doll with a receding hairline but
god damn it he's one of the best
personalities in the entire series I
can't imagine anyone else filling that
role and that's one of the issues I have
with jiren from a character's point of
view he has virtually nothing to set
himself apart from the crowd it was
Stern and quiet also yes but he was
introduced in a much shorter arc and had
a very interesting move set the latter
of which being the main reason tons of
people liked him again this is Dragon
Ball not Hemingway
we don't need nuanced ematic
deconstructions of Durin's hubris to
enjoy him but something to make him
stand out from the crowd wouldn't go
amiss either everything from what he
wears to what he says or doesn't say to
how he fights nothing about him is
unique or sensational in my opinion
anyway it worked because he is the only
one that could do what he did
characters like Goku Vegeta pick low or
even yeah gob can never be replaced this
is because they have personalities which
we have come to know and identify with
over the course of the show even a
character like Zuma soo was easy to
identify and understand
Geron is so overly simplistic that
literally anyone else could switch into
that role and
nothing would change as long as they
told us that they were the strongest or
whatever in my opinion he's a shell of a
character there's really nothing there
and before episode 127 you could barely
even say that he was a character but
once episode 127 came he did finally get
some exposition this was the spark that
got people turning their heads and
declaring Geron as a bad character to
break it down simply for the vast
majority of the tournament Geron was
given little to no dialogue no
development and absolutely no backstory
past the fact that he was part of the
Pride troopers and was SuperDuper strong
but when his backstory did eventually
surface with four episodes remaining
people were unsatisfied with how cliche
his past was and this is where I think
people are miss directing their
dissatisfaction just because something
is cliche doesn't make it inherently bad
things become cliché for a reason
specifically when they're used over and
over again and things are used over and
over again when they work the
prototypical hero's journey is in almost
every facet of fiction it's a staple
it's by no means bad I mean this is
Dragon Ball we're hardly expecting
Shakespeare levels of narrative
innovation in short there is nothing
wrong with having a character that lost
everything as a child to an evil force
dedicating the rest of his life to
ensuring he never feels that sense of
helplessness again while developing a
complex along the way in fact I kind of
like it so while I don't believe there
is anything wrong with Doran's backstory
personally I think how it was presented
was by and large the culprit for the
outrage in other words they took way too
long
to tell this otherwise simple story but
I have a theory that might explain some
of this away or at least shed some light
Durin's character I think was designed
early on but for the longest time
decisions were not finalized for what
the characters stood for what its goals
were and where he came from my reasoning
for thinking this his presence in the
promo material for the universe survival
arc
in January of 2017 the first animated
promo material aired for the universe
survival arc in which Geron was seen at
Bell modes side a position topo would be
soon swapped in for when the show
eventually aired this tells me one of
two things either Geron was there by
accident or his rule and backstory was
changed retroactively li leading to the
writers of the show intentionally under
developing him resulting in her first
proper meeting being at the tournament
of power and comparing that to the
mangas interpretation is even more
telling that introduction to cheerin
gives us more insight into his values
and character than 30 episodes of the
tournament of power ever did and that's
the problem
gerunds back story isn't sensational by
any means but it's not bad either the
only real issue I had with Joran was how
long it took them to establish this
information with a backstory revealed
four episodes out from the show's ending
how am i as a viewer expected to form a
connection with the character in any
meaningful way it's a little frustrating
because it clearly could have been
something that was established earlier
on to greater effect but with that said
the question remains is during a bad
character from the moment I was
introduced to Jaron I really didn't like
him and as the tournament progressed it
became more and more obvious to me that
Jaron was a hollow character the void of
anything that would interest me at all I
worried he might even ruin the climax of
the entire arc but I was wrong now in
saying that don't paint me as a jury
lover just yet Geron is not a fantastic
character he's not even a good character
he's fine nothing special and nothing
offensively bad and part of me believes
that this is at least on some level
intentional let me explain in one
sentence what I mean the tournament of
power isn't so much a unique arc as it
is a love letter to Dragon Ball now that
might seem like a load of flowery lip
service but think about it how many
iconic moments have been mimicked or
created thanks to this tournament
whether it be Goku's new transformation
a battle with a fuse character the
return of broli
friezes return from oblivion Master
Roshi's speech to Goku and krillen 18
and 17 working together giant monsters
Vegeta being tenacious which leads him
to releasing a blast reminiscent of a
sacrifice in the Buu saga I could easily
go on and I will Super Saiyan God go on
and Goku's kamehameha together
Piccolo's interaction with calming and
male Krillin 18 working together
Gohan blocking a blast just like piccolo
did for him when he was a child this arc
it was designed from the start to be the
last of Super it's Swan son but when
this tournament began none of us knew
that I like many thought things were
going to continue right after much like
it did when the Future Trunks arc ended
and so I hated Juran because I thought
he was going to be the focus
the reason this arc existed to establish
him as a character but he's not the
focus he never was all this time I was
complaining that he wasn't getting the
development he needed when clearly the
focus has been on reliving Dragon Balls
greatest hits rather than specific new
characters Jaron is nothing special he
is there to facilitate these incredible
moments nothing more than a plot device
and he does that job perfectly fine the
real star of the universe survival arc
is Dragon Balls history and it takes
center stage if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to leave a like and if
you'd like to see more content like this
why not try subscribing it's good karma
or if you guys would like to see who I
think is gonna win the tournament why
not try clicking this video down here
and if facts are more your thing why not
check out the scoreboard I made for the
tournament to power last week who do you
think has the most eliminations but I'll
do it for this week thank you so much
for watching